nick is with us in Chattanooga hi Nick
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
it's good to talk to you you too man
what's up okay so I'm 25 I have I've
done pretty well for myself I have a
dilemma though my Achilles heel is cars
I have a car it's a 2009 Chrysler 300
bucks the srt8 model with a big Hemi in
it and it's a be stopped yes I paid well
below Kelley Blue Book value and I have
about five to six thousand dollars worth
of equity in the car and I've been
listening you and going through your
baby steps it's gonna be tough for me
but I think I need to sell a car I know
you're going to tell me to sell the car
and use the money to finish my emergency
fund what is your what is your car worth
private market is 23 to I think and you
said you're 25 and you're doing pretty
well for yourself tell me what that
means that means I have a good job I've
got 21 thousand dollars invested by
retirement I have no credit card debt
are you single
I'm single and what's your income my
income is about forty five to fifty
thousand dollars a year give or take a
little bit with over tom is this your
only debt on the car
that's my only debt and how much do you
owe on it Oh
sixteen thousand two hundred fifty two
dollars and 21 cents as a single guy
can't you pay that in a year if you have
no life but you get to keep the car no
life you don't see the inside of a
freaking restaurant less you're working
there I've been doing that Dave I've
overing almost yeah all right yeah I
mean I've been doing everything and that
but Kent I mean you can probably pay
sixteen thousand Danny or making 50
grand if you're single can't you yes sir
I'd keep the car
okay let me tell you how dad let me tell
you how did the analysis it's not how
much you love the car or how cool a car
it is although both are valid because it
is a seriously cool car but the analysis
is this can you be debt-free except your
house in under two years the answer is
yes and are your vehicles the total of
all your vehicles worth less less than a
half your annual income and the answer
is barely yes and you really love this
car so you're willing to fight for it to
keep it don't have more than half your
annual income tied up in stuff that goes
down in value dude that's from one car
guy to another car guy okay I got lots
of cars but they're less than 1% them on
that worth dude so just if you're gonna
have toys go get some money first and
then you can have toys this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]